Harry and I are on stage now and really
have the distinct pleasure to announce
and confer this year's winners of the
microsoft research faculty fellowships
this is something that we've been doing
now for 10 years and for us it is a way
to work with all of you to really
identify people who we think show
exceptional promise young faculty
members worldwide who threw a cash award
given by microsoft research as well as
just being welcomed into the microsoft
research family in a number of workshops
research collaborations shared student
mentoring and so on really we hope gave
us a meaningful way to really inspire
all new faculty members around the world
to be excellent and to be great and also
to work with us and so today we have 66
faculty fellows and and they really are
all great colleagues of ours and and
have all moved on to having really
important careers in in the research
community and so without further delay
I'd like to announce this year's
microsoft research faculty fellows and
so we will start with why why on from
India and University in Bloomington
next beyond gone Chun from Seoul
National University Diego Fernandez
Slezak from the University of Buenos
Aires Roxanna Jim Basu from columbia
university / si Lang from Stanford
University David stir from Cornell
University and Vinod if I could to
nothin from MIT and yes I did practice
so please join me and again
congratulating all of our wonderful 2014
microsoft research faculty fellows